[Music]  dr. show you boys how you do it daddy  higher for the foster babies  try to keep up  so scrolls are the bad guys  and you're a Cree a race of noble  warriors heroes noble warrior heroes  [Music]  your life began the day it nearly ended  we found you with no memory we made you  one of us so you could live longer  stronger superior  you were reborn  I keep having these  memories something in my past is the key  to all of this  you're not a wladis thing you'll see  that's a yes or no question  yes  [Music]  would you like to know  what you really are  [Music]  I think I had a life here  what aren't you telling me  we've come a long way but you know as  strong as you think  this war is just the beginning  I'm not going to fight your war  [Music]  I'm gonna end it  [Music]  I'm sure the cutest little thing aren't  you  what's your name  [Music]